Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton faced off
in the first presidential debate of the season.
Here it is in 3:00 minutes.
They were both terrible in their own unique
ways.
Trump talked a lot about law and order
and touted New York City’s rights-violating stop-and-frisk policy.
We have to bring back law and order.
Now wether or not, in a place like Chicago,
you do stop and frisk, which worked very well,
Mayor Giuliani is here, worked very well in
New York.
It brought the crime rate way down.
Of course, murder rates were going down before
stop-and-frisk, went down during stop-and-frisk,
and have continued to go down after New Yorkers’
right to walk down a sidewalk without being
intimately touched by an armed agent of the
state was restored.
Clinton’s response was to point at guns...
We've got too many military-style weapons
on the streets.
In a lot of places our police are out-gunned.
...despite the fact that gun violence is also
at an all-time low nationwide.
Most people watching the debate are going
to remember where the candidates disagreed,
but to libertarians, the perhaps more disturbing areas
are those where the candidates are in agreement.
Even though Trump talked a big game about
debt reduction...
We owe 20 trillion dollars... 20 trillion
in debt... we're a debtor nation...
...both agreed that we just don’t spend
enough.
Let's have paid family leave.
Trump tried to outdo Hillary’s $30 billion
a year family leave government mandate...
As far as child care is concerned and so many
other things
I think Hillary and I agree on that.
....with his own family leave plan and other
spending proposals that would increase the
debt by $11.5 trillion over 10 years.
Unlike Trump, Clinton acknowledged the possibility
that international trade is a good thing…
Well I think that trade is an important issue.
Of course, we are 5% of the world's population,
we have to trade with the other 95%.
But after the primary campaign, both candidates
now agree
that the deals we have are killing us.
You want to approve Trans-Pacific Partnership.
You were totally in favor of it, then you
heard what I was saying, how bad it is, and
you said 'I can't win that debate.'
That, that is just not accurate.
I was against it once it was finally negotiated.
Leaving nobody on stage to defend the principle
of free trade.
If you're too dangerous to fly, you are too
dangerous to buy a gun.
The most egregious area of total agreement
was on the issue of gun rights and government lists.
Pass a prohibition on anyone who's on the
Terrorist Watch List
from being able to buy a gun in our country.
I think we have to look very strongly at no-fly
lists and watch lists and when people are
on there, even if they shouldn't be on there,
we'll help them, we'll help them legally, we'll help them get off.
Once again, Americans didn’t get a chance
to hear a principled argument
about individual rights, the Constitution, and due process.
While the debate had its fair share of strange
and entertaining moments….
I call it... trumped-up trickle-down.
I will release my tax returns against my lawyer's
wishes.
When she releases her 33 thousand emails that
have been deleted.
As soon as she releases them, I will release,
I will release, my tax returns.
And that's against my lawyers.
They said 'don't do it.'
American voters were cheated out of a full
debate that represents the true diversity
of political thought and opinion that exists
in this country.
Instead, they got what they almost always
get:
the chance to choose between two bad candidates.